why are we asking these questions what
does it come to in our life right hey
everyone I'm Abbi short welcome to a DS
kitchen and I'm here with my friend
dietitian avi Langer so we had so much
fun talking a little bit about so the
craziest diets we've seen out there and
a lot of you at home asked us to
actually try some of these out
you owe us one you really do so we're
gonna kick things off with a little
liquid plumr bottles that girl oh my
gosh so this has six pounds of greens in
it which is pretty much the about that
spectrum of your body after you can see
with one bottle of this it's not the
same thing as eating your vegetables but
it's ten bucks ten dollars for putrid
pus water yeah it's not sexy alright
number two
Shakeology this is four dollars and 33
cents it's 160 calories thought they
call it a meal replacement this is not a
meal replacement it's a snap it says the
healthiest meal of the day
oh God try it smells like like
it's a little tiny people drink this
like multiple times in the days this
just send us more boring gum chewer Ella
Sacha Inchi this is like Gwyneth Paltrow
is grocery list and it's scaring the
[ __ ] out of ya I really need to write
Braska ollege Shera
just write kale like it's hey guys
speaking of 160 calories of delicious
goodness this is 160 calories of real
food like chicken and avocado would you
rather eat this than this vile
concoction
you got like finally you got lots of
protein you've got so many great
nutrients you don't need to worry about
this chocolate choc July closes okay
last but not least we have raw till 4
which was made famous by everyone's
favorite - YouTube celebrity really
Hannah girl freely breakfast is your raw
till 4 milkshake 7 bananas 3 cups of
water a cup of coconut water a
tablespoon of coconut sugar and vanilla
as money 7 bananas for breakfast
alright lunch is a mono meal a meal
consisting of one ingredient sounds
excited raw
snack time unlimited fresh fruit till 4
p.m. because you're craving fruit of
course dinner is 500 grams of organic
potatoes pop your cat cappy's come back
and that's some low sodium dipping sauce
it's a horrible diet
we eat this much project in the morning
shake alone there's this much sugar this
much sugar in the more wine meal you're
gonna eat your shake your thousand
calorie milkshake in the morning and be
like I still need a big map because
obviously I believe in goddamn bananas
today
you're sure okay let's make this goddamn
shake do it so we've got three cups of
water here so I'm gonna pad that coconut
especially dae-ho
just she just like five boxes a banana
it's getting worse and worse it's like
just bananas like mush bananas this is
your breakfast every day every day for
the rest of your life it's like being in
prison
really the bananas gotta go yeah fruit
yourself really yeah fruit yourself and
no one else please please no one else do
this I took Bart I have really happy